okay
put a finger down if you thought this
talk would not happen and you just down
the pint and now you have to give it
anyway
let's see how it goes
so
welcome everybody i'm super excited to
be here with you today uh for quite a
few reasons actually it's the first time
i'm speaking in ndc london
and it is the city i've spent the last
10 years of my life so
super excited to be on this and and talk
to you about controllers and minimal
apis
so quick intro
hey my name is nick chapstos
this slide is a bit outdated i'm not
working for checkout anymore however you
should check that company out great
company great employer
you should give it a chance if you're
thinking into moving into fintech a
bunch of other stuff you probably know
me from my youtube channel
and i also have some courses on my own
website the website nickjabs.com
if you want to give that a go for topics
like minimal apis as well
so
let's dive straight into the topic which
is minimal apis now how many of you know
what minimal apis are sort of hands
okay and how many of you think it's
something you will never put in anywhere
near production
okay i mean
so the goal is to not think that way by
the end of this talk now in case you
didn't know
minimal apis are by far the most loved
feature of the dot net 6 release i mean
everybody just loves them it is amazing
to see people come together and embrace
the simplicity of using minimal apis and
really thinking that adopting something
that other languages have been doing for
years and moving away from controllers
is something that we really can do in
this community this joke is going for
way too long in reality
people are a bit mixed about them to say
the least
i mean some say that they're junk
okay let's see if we can change that
opinion
so
what are minimal apis now this is the
point where i could be very
sophisticated and have a fancy quote and
explain what they are but you do know
what they say one picture is worth 1 000
lines of code so here's a picture with
four lines of code
so this is fundamentally what minimal
apis are about it's this idea that we
can strip down everything about me
building apis in.net and this file is a
valid api
in c sharp now that's a bit of a lie the
only other file you need for this to be
a valid api is actually a cs prog file
which specifies this as a web project
but once you have that there are no
using statements there are no name
spaces no classes no public static void
main string array odds and so on and so
forth you just have that now some people
are a bit intimidated by this simplicity
and they think that this is immature
this is not something they ever want to
attach where are my controllers
well let's investigate that claim a
little bit
but i want to emphasize something this
is not something you you might be
thinking what a damn minute
that thing over there that looks a whole
lot like that thing now blink it you
miss it the top thing is minimal apis in
c sharp and dot net the bottom one is
express.js from the node world so this
idea of going from point zero to point
i have an api very very easily and very
very quickly is not novel it's how jes
has been building api for years and
it's not really limited in the js world
for example python with fast api this
idea that all you need is that fast api
app and then you specify the endpoint
and you have the hello ndc
very very simple very very easy to get
started let's go ahead go lovely
language many people love it when people
use it same thing you have gin a
framework which allows you to create an
app and then have that get or post or
put or delete and just quickly return a
string or anything that you want and
build an api on that
let's go ahead anyone remember nancy
over here nancy fx do you remember this
being a thing so this used to be a thing
in c-sharp all we need you need to do is
have this get and then you point to a
delegate that returns a string and that
would return
that text
now
note kind of faded away for other
reasons what which we are going to
investigate as i go on and it was
reincarnated in the form of a project
called carter
but i don't think you should really use
that as opposed to minimal apis at this
point
but we're going to talk about that as
well as i go on
and also i'll go on with sinatra which
is what nancy affects nancy sinatra
sinatra that's the whole name thing um
you just have get you have the end point
and you have the hello world and that is
it so clearly for years this is very
very old actually the need to get from
nothing to something that returns some
data on the web has been around
and if you actually look deep down
inside other languages controllers and
that whole concept of building apis with
them
isn't really much of a thing unless they
have
mvc into a framework for example ruby on
rails
but you might be wondering how is that
even possible how can we just have these
four lines of code with no using
statements no namespaces no classes no
nothing and that is an api well i made a
bit of an animation to show you how that
is possible
all those features from c sharp 9 um
10 and dot net 6 apis are coming
together you can tell about like how
proud i am about this because it has a
watermark with my name on it because i
don't want people to steal it
it took me a long time to make but this
is how minimal apis are coming together
let's see it again it took me three
hours to make
so these features are just coming
together to give us minimal apis i'm
going to skip this early no let's just
say i don't know how big the power
rangers were in here but back home in
greece they were a bit of a deal
so this is how this is possible and
we're gonna see every single feature uh
to see how we got here so top level
statements are actually an c-sharp 9
feature
which i kind of hated when it came out
but in c-sharp 8 you have to have that
using statement that namespace
which is optional but you had it anyway
then the program class then the public
static avoid the mainstream array args
as if
we're insane and we're writing java for
some reason
and then we have the actual meat of the
application which is the
console.writeline and then hello world
so with top level statements we no
longer need that all we have to do is to
say using system and then
console.writeline.helloworld
and yes i could cheat if i did really
want to and just merge system with the
console but then i couldn't have this
amazing segue into the next feature
which is implicit using statements so
that problem we no longer have that
because the c-sharp team said well
there's actually around seven namespaces
that you're gonna import on every single
file most of the time anyway so why
don't we just imply that they exist
already and then as long as you say yeah
use implicit using statements in that cs
profile then you can just say that you
don't need system
which is another awesome segue to the
next feature global using statements
because now what i can do is i can have
a file a cs file that has global using
and the statement hence the name
and then that will be automatically
imported in every single file which is
coincidentally exactly what this flag
will do on the cs proj the enable flag
because it will actually kick in a
source generator behind the scenes that
will drop
that exact file so implicit using
statements are a bit of a mixture of
global using statements and source
generators
also in third lambda types until c-sharp
9 the compiler here has all the
information it needs to determine that
this is a function that accepts a string
and returns a string but if you try to
do var or try to maybe inline this
lambda somewhere the compiler will be
like i really don't know what this thing
is supposed to be can you please specify
it and you either have to cast it or
create a new func of something so it was
a bit frustrating and there wasn't
really need for them to make it
being fed but now in c sharp 10 we do
have that because the dotnet team kind
of needed this for minimal apis to make
sense if you actually saw early demos of
minimal apis the people who were demoing
them especially scott hunter i think he
had to cast it and it did look a bit
ugly so it's great that we have this
here now
then the last picture that we got is
attributes on lambdas so previously this
would not compile you could not have the
attribute the obsolete attribute on the
lambda itself
now you can and this makes sense because
if you think of minimal apis if you have
seen them before and we're going to see
them in a second now you can actually
specify things like allow anonymous or
authorized attributes on the lambda
itself
but enough with that what i want to do
is i want to go into a demo just to make
sure everyone is on the same page
so
let's go and do this i don't know why
i'm doing a live demo i probably hate
myself but let's give it a go and hope
it doesn't fail so what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to create a minimal
api
and the first thing i need to do is just
say minimal api dot demo and create a
console app i'm explicitly not making an
asp.net core application or a web
project just to show you how from
nothing you can actually create a
minimal api
so project is created can i have a
thumbs up if you can see this or if not
i can all good okay if at any point you
can't please shout and i will change it
so i'm gonna go ahead over here and i'm
just gonna go to the cs proj of this
project and i'm going to change the sdk
to have a dot web and that's all you
need a console app now magically is
turned into a web api now the web api
has two fundamental components the web
application builder which is where you
do all the configuration for your api
and then the web application itself
which is where you configure all the
middleware so let's go ahead and see
that i'm going to create the builder
first so i'm going to say builder equals
webapplication.createbuilder and i can
actually access the arguments of the
program.cs as if they were there so i'm
going to pass them down in case someone
wants to pass down some settings so
that's my first construct then i have
the application itself so it's a
materialization of the web application
builder so dot bill goes here and then
app.run
and that's it i have my api at this
point it doesn't have any endpoints
obviously
but i can add them in here
and effectively all this really is
because you might be thinking well
where's startup.cs where is my
configuration where's everything
well you can treat this area over here
as the configure method of the
startup.cs and you can treat this area
over here as the configure services
of your starter.cs so anything in here
you configure once you materialize your
application you cannot actually
retroactively update anything so if i
was to access
services and add a service once my app
has been created well that is no longer
applicable it won't change because i
have my app already here so let's go
ahead and create our first endpoint and
all i need to do is say app dot
map get and i'm gonna have your typical
hello world so
that's all i need hello ndc
and i got that now in order for me to
run this without having to stop and
start on my id i'm actually gonna go to
the terminal
and do
one of these so i'm gonna say minimal
api dot demo here we go and i'm gonna
say dot net watch run but i'm gonna
choose not to use the hot reload feature
see that's my choice i
don't use it because i want to imagine
if someone thought
removing this feature is a good idea
anyway that would never happen
anyway so this will now start
let's give it a second and now every
time i update this file the application
would restart so i have that and the way
to call this without having to go to
postman or another application is i have
a bunch of predetermined requests in
this http file and writer my id allows
me to call them so i can call that
endpoint and of course it didn't show me
what the response is but you can see it
here hello ndc i get response
back so if i go back i can do other
things as well i can say map get
and i can say for example hello
object and i can just create
a brand new anonymous object here it
doesn't have to be
a real one all i can say is message
equals and then have my text hello ndc
very easily and i can also actually mix
a couple of other things as well i'm
going to create a record over here
called user
with a full name
and i'm also going to use a class called
results so i can say
user
and then return from the results class
which effectively has a bunch of
predetermined ways to return a request
so text stream unauthorized bad request
sign in sign out all the typical things
you would also have in the mvc world all
of them are here so i'm gonna go ahead
and say just okay and create a new user
and of course it will be
me
okay so with all those done i'm just
gonna pretend like
i'm pausing so the hot reload restarts
hello hello and this works you can see
serialization takes care of the case as
well it's not capital m you can
customize all that and also if i want to
get the user
everything just automatically works out
of the box now i can actually also
access a bunch of special parameters
here because until now
everything is parameter-less we don't
really use anything from the request we
just return something so let's go ahead
and do that i'm going to go ahead and
say special over here and i'm going to
access a few special parameters and i'm
just going to return an anonymous object
so the first thing i want to access is
actually the http context
so i can say context and this now will
be automatically injected and gives me
access to things like the connection the
features the items the requests the
response everything now for my taste
that is a bit of a quite wide object and
i wouldn't really use that in
any case really so what i want to do
instead is access the http
request
directly
if i want something from the request and
i can also break it down and access the
http
response directly right so
i can do a few things with this first
i can actually write to the response
with a json object which means i no
longer
need
this new return i can take control and
return that and we're gonna return
a few things from the request but it
also means that because this is an async
method
i can change this delegate to be async
as well let's make this like that and
let's delete this actually so you can
see what's going on
and i can say
a weight over here so now i can grab
something from a request for example
request dot
query and that's the query collection
and if i save and i give it some time to
recycle and go back and run this special
request then you can see that it's
grabbing
that age parameter and it's printing it
over here
so very simple there's other special
parameters you can access as well for
example you can get access to the
cancellation token if for some reason
you want to pass it down in fact rider
my id is telling me hey i can do
something with this cancellation token
let me just pass it down for you so here
we go and then the last thing i want to
show is how you can do a more
extravagant request which brings in a
lot of the stuff that i just showed you
for example what if you want parameters
like a query string parameter or route
parameter or the body of a request so
many things to choose or even a header
so let's go ahead and do that i'm going
to say map get in fact map post again
and yes there is a map method
for a bunch of different things map
delete map get map post map put there is
no
patch i don't know if they're going to
add it it's not like i'm using patch
anyway so it's fine
for me
extra is the endpoint i'm creating and
let's say i want to pass down a
parameter from the route so let's say i
want to pass down the year
parameter from the route it's the exact
same thing you do in controllers you
specify it like that and then you can
map it
to a parameter over here let's say you
want to have a query string parameter
called age
well you don't really need to do
anything for that it just magically
works because it implies that if it's
not specified here
then it's probably coming from the query
string
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to print them so you can see them when i
call this so i'm going to say age now
let's say
i want something from the header because
if you see over here what i'm going to
call this
i actually have an accept header so what
i can say is string accept but here's a
bit of a problem
this doesn't know how to map the accept
header it will assume that accept is a
question parameter because it's more of
a common thing to do so the default
behavior is this so instead i'm gonna
say
from header and be explicit about it
and last but not least because as you
saw on this request i also have a full
name i'm going to pass down from the
body
a user
and as if this wasn't chaotic enough let
me just
pass this down i'm gonna go ahead and
copy from this file this
datetime provider class
which allows me to have mockup date in
my application so for that to be able to
be injected i need to go up here and
register it so builder.services.add
singleton i daytime provider and then
daytime provider
cool cool okay so what i can do now is i
can also inject i date time provider
now
that's quite a lot of implicit
statements
but
if i go back here
and i call that api request
then it all magically gets mapped
well with code
so
you can also be explicit if you want to
for example if for some reason the h
parameter you want it to have a
different name in the header or the
query you can also say for example name
equals a and then what you can do is go
back here age is a and so on and so
forth those are the basic constructs and
you still have it mapped over here so i
hope we are now all on the same page on
what this thing is because
we kind of need to put that in context
because i'm assuming all of you know
what nvc is and what the controller is
and what web api is
and this talk will be a bit critical
about those constructs now
so with all that said then let me just
cancel this because if i forget it i
might fail the next demo
so
let me move on let's address something
there are a few unsupported features in
minimal apis it's not it's not all happy
days uh if it was everybody would be
using them hopefully the first thing is
there is no support for filters so so
things like the async action filters the
result filters the exception filters
those things are not supported this
support is actually being added in dot
net seven
however they're a bit of a different
thing i mean it's still the same concept
but you cannot reuse your filters that
you have on mvc in minimal api so you're
going to have to remap them
but it is coming
then there is no built-in support for
validation so as you saw we did have
model binding but a model validator
would not work for example if i tried to
have a required header in my model even
if the value wasn't there this thing
would not throw an exception so you'd
have to write your own validators
which for me is fine because i'm using
fluent validator and i'm wiring it up in
nvc anyway so
there's not much of a problem for me but
i can totally see how this can be of
pudding for some people
there is also no support like i showed
you for json patch again
something i never really had to use but
i can totally see how some people would
benefit off of having that
and likewise for our data our data is
not supported
and that's all i'm going to say about
that
and also last but not least there is no
built-in support for api versioning now
this is not the concept of api
versioning you can have api versioning
if you want you can just make a folder
call it v1 put it in the namespace yada
yada but you cannot use the api
versioning mvc package which has all of
that automated for you and you can have
it in a header the media accept media i
think header or a question parameter or
part of the route that is not supported
i think that's because it's based on
filters for some stuff and we didn't
have filters so someone might remake
that in the future but as far as i know
it is not supported currently
but
i want to address another problem which
is actually caused by me showing you
that program.cs file and it's called the
program.cs hell
so
the other day which when i wrote this
was the other day this is actually seven
months ago
is this tweet by someone who said that
hey i chose to build the minimal api
because dotnet six is out and minimal
api is the new thing so i'm gonna use
that and i ended up with six methods the
mapget methods in that program.cs six
classes they hate themselves they feel
that this is wrong why are they doing
this web api just feels better
who thinks the minimal api actually who
thinks that web api is better than
minimal api can i see a show of hands
okay okay
so
what's the last time
anyone not not just the people who
disagreed what's the last time
that you you created an api let's let's
say it was a customer's api an api that
manages customers in your domain and you
created the customers controller and
then in that controller class you also
slapped your customers mapper customers
validator customers service customers
repository any of core stuff maybe
mediator was in there as well
you didn't because your software
engineers and you structure your code
minimal apis are not different minimal
apis are not about having everything in
a single file
they're about stripping down everything
to its basics so you can choose your own
destiny and build the structure that you
want so let's recap what minimal apis
are not
they're not one line one file apis i
know it's very convenient for demos for
people like me to show you everything in
one file because i don't have to jump
around in 50 different files and explain
what this controller and this service
and this repository and how everything
is injected you just have everything in
that single file and it's very
convenient they're also not just for
demos
but like i just said they're very
convenient for demos because everything
is in that single file i have this
choice do you think that if that was the
choice in the past i would have a
program.cs a startup.cs a controller a
service a repository and so on and so
forth no because that can be confusing
for demos
but also not just for beginners some
people think it is just for beginners
but as we're gonna see later in this
talk i really don't think that this is
the gate the case they're great for
beginners because it delivers to that
promise of from nothing to an api that
returns something very very easily the
same promise that sinatra nancy and
those other apis had
but it's not just for them in fact the
concept of a minimal api can be tied
very nicely into another minimalistic
concept that many of you i'm sure are
using
and last but not least they're not going
to kill controllers i know many people
think that this is the case and that
microsoft will actually make controllers
obsolete in favor of minimal apis a lot
of that discussion has actually started
because someone who is working on
minimal apis by microsoft has replied in
a comment that they expect 70 to 80
percent of all the future use cases to
be done with minimal apis i think it's a
bit of an optimistic metric i think many
of them will be eventually adopted but
70 to 80 yeah
i don't think so
and i also did crunch the numbers after
extensive research and i did find out
that if
microsoft were to choose
to kill controllers they would break
approximately 100 percent of all the
software out there running apis in
and dot net it's not going to happen
so
i want to take a minute now and before i
go
to this mini rand
i want to take a second and just address
the elephant in the room it is it is a
bit of a rant this one it's i won't bore
you too much it's only like 50 bullet
points but we'll get there
um
controllers for building apis are weird
there i said it
how many of you think that they're not
weird then they're great for building
apis so fans
okay
so
they're weird for a few reasons now why
do you think we're using controllers
when we're building apis in dot-net do
you think the 10 smartest people in
microsoft sat down and they said
well it does look like that
architecturally and structurally and
everything really it makes sense to have
controllers as the way to build apis and
net that is not the case the only reason
why we have them
is because
ruby on rails was a thing and then
microsoft thought well we kind of need
an mvc framework as well and they built
nbc and controllers do
endpoint
routing model binding and validation so
they were like can we just rebrand this
to another thing call it web api and
call it a day and just give it to people
and say
this amazing new way to build apis is
here just use it
that's the only reason why they're
called controllers they could be modules
there could be endpoints that would be
anything as far as like here i i don't
care
but we have to acknowledge the fact that
this is not the starting point
controllers are just
one of the end goals and it's one of the
many end goals usually you start with
minimal apis or the equivalent in a
language and you get there
but here's the thing because we're using
control s which is the c on mvc
but what's the last time you use the
view when you're using a controller
because the whole point of having a
controller is it's part of mvc but you
don't use views
so why are we using mvc contracts to
build apis
and likewise
m
the models
in mvc is more about business logic it
isn't really about dtos and api
contracts and in fact when you're
building apis a different thing is
coming in a different thing is going out
usually so
what's the point of using
we're just left with c why are we using
an nvc thing and we just normalized that
yeah this is this is fine this is
acceptable it is not
but the reason why it is
is that it was actually the only viable
way to build apis and yeah someone might
say hey nick nancyfx was a thing i was
using it it was great well the truth is
for it to be dead not enough people were
actually using it
and also people are just
prone to not adopting something that it
isn't supported officially by microsoft
minimal apis are and now controllers are
as well and we're gonna see how that
goes as the time moves on
they also have these methods these
actions that never really call each
other you would never have one action
call another action and if you're doing
that
don't
and the reason why they exist in that
controller is because it made sense
because in the mvc world the view would
actually refer to both the controller
and the action by name or sometimes just
the action by name so you'd have
entirely sense it would make sense that
everything would be grouped logically
because it isn't the black box that is
calling those endpoints it is your view
so why are we using that again
and then the kind of low-key violating
responsibility because you might think
it's not because you say hey nick my
domain is the customer i have customers
controller customer controller and
everything is in there my create my
update my delete everything is there no
violation well i would argue that it
also kind of violates open closed on top
of that because every time you want to
go ahead and add an end point you have
to go and change that existing class
that has nothing to do with you adding
an end point or deleting one in my
opinion they should be separated in
separate endpoints
so
let me just quick intermission because
i'm a bit tired
okay
so they also have these services
injected into them into the actions
or the controller actually but they're
not used sometimes by all the actions so
you would allocate an object in that
controller being instantiated and then
you would waste all that memory for
allocating that object and have to
garbage collected as well even though
it's not used by all actions
so why are we doing that and someone
might say hey nick i'm using the from
services attribute and i'm only
injecting it in the method itself
if you're doing that great i haven't
really seen it all i see is the lazy way
of just go with the constructor and just
hope it we don't care about memory
basically
um and also they never share state
between action so why are they sharing
real estate because they're all scoped
anyway and you wouldn't call one another
so what's the whole point of having them
together i don't get it and when you
have private methods they usually are
only called by a single action they
wouldn't be called my multiple actions
most of the time
and middleware and filters that you have
because it is coming from nvc a lot of
that was actually just left in there
from mvc
and for example validation is called
everywhere
so
you have to be comparatively slower than
minimal apis as well because you have to
invoke and allocate those objects and
even if it's just a nif check to walk
out of the flow uh minimal apis have a
10 to 15 realistically percent
performance boost over controllers i
won't dive too much into the performance
point because performance is contextual
and it doesn't mean the same thing for
everyone like if you have a database
that takes a second to respond
minimal apis won't just magically make
your apa fast
um they can also grow quite a lot and we
have this
questionable term called fat controllers
and we just do everything we can to just
remove stuff from those controllers
because someone is like so proud when
they have oh like my controller is just
three lines of code
that's how simple it needs to be
well how do you how about you remove
that controller together if it needs to
be so simple you don't need it move the
mapping outside send the thing to
mediator which is what you're going to
do anyway and just move on with your
life
so this is what it can
look like for a new developer working in
as a junior developer or as a seasoned
developer from a simpler ecosystem like
node like python like go
so they just want to build an api
but then
they have all those things dropped on
them
and it can certainly be overwhelming and
sometimes we forget that some people
just want to build apis they don't want
to build sorry just want to build
products they don't necessarily want to
build your clean architecture with three
layers and onion and hexagonal and all
those fancy words that
you probably don't need
so what is this talk about really well
like with everything in this life
it's all about lego
it's always about lego
i promise it will make sense
what do you see here just silently in
your mind
think about what you see here
if you say you see a half-finished
lego set of hogwarts
you're wrong
i mean that's the right answer but
that's not what i'm getting
so what you have here
is the foundations of some castle
i can see some windows i can see a door
there is some structure to this thing
it's not finished but there's certainly
some structure i can also see a window
this way and there's no back wall
now what's great about this structure is
that if i give it to my nephew who's
five
and i say completed just because of how
much foundation there is there and how
much work has been done by default
they will probably finish with something
like this i mean they're five so maybe
it looks a bit worse but something
around that
but also
me who is not an architect and i don't
know how to build castles if i take that
and i'm i've done my fair bit of lego
but i'm not a castle expert
i can still create a fairly good looking
castle something like this
now let's take a step back
i go to my nephew again
and instead of giving them an unfinished
castle i give them ground and i give
them a backup a bucket with infinite
amount of lego of any size any color any
length
and i say
build a castle
well they're gonna probably build
something like this now
does it look like a castle
if i ask him he'll be like yeah he's
certainly a castle i can see a door i
can see the ground there's a torch
somewhere there it is amazing
now i wouldn't say it looks like a
castle i think it looks bad i wouldn't
tell it to him because he would cry but
at least he's engaged and he got into
using lego and to his eyes he did build
a castle
and he can play with a castle and you
know what next time he builds another
costume maybe maybe it will be less
shitty
but
if i go to my uncle
who studied
architecture
and i gave the same tools
then most likely he would make a
masterpiece
do you get it
that's what that's what minimal apis are
all about
this is what controllers look like like
to me
there's a lot of opinions about
something in there there's a lot of
stuff on how it should be built your
model validator your
model state how you can extend that
specific controller base how you need an
api con
controller attribute all of those
details on how you should structure your
project and what it should do by default
are there and what's great about that is
because a junior developer most likely
will build an api that looks like this
because once you have that controller
set up it's very unlikely you're going
to fundamentally
mess it up
but
someone who's mid or senior as well can
take the exact same thing and build
maybe a bit of a of a better one uh of a
castle but again a nice looking customer
but here's the thing with minimal apis
if i
break down everything to the bare
minimum and i go ahead and i give them
to a junior developer or someone who has
never built an api before but all they
care about is to build the product and
the product happens to need an api and i
say look how simple it is to build an
api you have all of these lego bricks
and a ground
go ahead go crazy
they will be happy because they did
build an api that works for them is it a
well architected api
no
does it matter if it works for them
no because next time they're going to
build it it will be pretty good
but
what happens with someone who's a true
senior staff principal whatever word
they invented today for calling very
similar engineers if i give that to one
of those people one of those architects
then they most certainly will build a
masterpiece and a masterpiece that works
for them
and that's exactly what minimal apis are
about it is about you it is about choice
so
let's go back to the first question
what are minimal apis
well to me
minimal apis are an opinionated way to
build high performance apis in dot net
with the minimal amount of implicitly
added features and the maximal amount of
flexibility to explicitly obtain the
features and the structure that you need
it's about you it's about choice
so let's see what is possible when you
can have that sort of power in your
hands
let's go back to the first demo actually
the second demo
and i'm gonna go ahead and i have this
api over here which i'm not gonna show
you what's in there
but i'm just going to run it and all you
need to know
is that this api is a customer's api
microservice and it is a rest api
so i'm just going to make this smaller
i'm going to expand this and i'm going
to show you the end points so you have
your classic rest get all resources in a
given
api thing so no customers in my system
this is using a real database by the way
with the right responses and headers and
everything
then i can go ahead if i want and create
a user so let me just mess up my email a
bit so that is definitely not my email
but if i am to create a user
and let me just find it here you can see
that a.com is not a valid email address
so i have full validation here i can
also for example use the date in the
future and try to call that
and it says your date of birth cannot be
in the future so full model validation
and domain level validation for my thing
um that's definitely not when i was born
now i'll be ancient
uh and i'm gonna go ahead and create me
and i can go ahead and get me as well
from that getting point
so i'm back
i can also mess that
end point a bit and point to something
that doesn't exist and i get a 402
exactly as you would do in a rest api if
you say that this should return 204
you are wrong
and i can go ahead and update this as
well so my username will be different so
i have exactly what you need for rest
api and then just to wrap this up
i'm just gonna call delete and i'm gone
204 no content the user was deleted and
if i do it again
404 resource not found now
let's take a look at something else i'm
going to go to swagger i'm going to
refresh this page and this is the
schwager
please move okay
and this is a swagger from my api
now i have to look at this because it
wasn't updating
and you can see my endpoints here
documented creates a new customer in the
system i have my request body i have the
success code so 201 400
get delete
yet again and put everything is here
with exactly what you'd expect from an
api that respects itself
now how is that done with minimal api
technology because all of that that you
just saw is built with minimal apis
now here's the api
remember apis minimal apis are not about
the minimal amount of code it is about
the minimal amount of setup code and
stripping down everything to its bare
minimum so for me an endpoint looks
something like this
all i need to have
is a class an endpoint class which for
this to be registered all i need to do
is create it and then i extend the
endpoint class i slap an http post here
and allow anonymous and then i have my
request and my response very explicit
very descriptive i can inject any
service i want in here and i only have a
single handle method because that thing
is supposed to be one thing and one
thing only to handle this create
customer request and then i'm sending
that to a service because i don't need
mediator in this case and then i'm just
returning it back as a created ad with
the like the right location header and
all that
and if i wanted to add an extra endpoint
to my api i just create a new class
extending the same things
now i also have validation for those
things and again those are implicitly
registered all i needed to do is extend
the abstract validator which if you are
familiar with fluent validation this
definitely rings a bell
and then point to that request over
there so that
just magically works with code and then
last but not least the summaries those
are what is used for the documentation
in swagger so if i went ahead and i
deleted that then that documentation
would be gone and again i didn't have to
explicitly register any of that now how
this all hangs together and you can find
this code by the way on my github under
a clean minimal api which is ironic
is like this i have a package installed
called fast end points which i helped
steer the direction a little bit uh
because i found it very interesting and
it's what i wanted to do with minimal
apis as well and i was glad someone else
was doing that and i can just
help with that
and then that's all i need to do to
register my services and then this is
all i need to do to register my
endpoints and that's it i'm not cheating
by the way all i have in here is just
some error response mapping to a
validation contract which again i can
just extract to a different class but
that's it
so
i just want to recap this is still
technically using minimal api code now
you might think that this is
too much this is a lot this is bloated
however it is the path i chose and this
is the half the custom i decided to
build
and that's my choice which is what
minimal apis are all about
so
back to this
let's talk about something that i call
minimal valley and it's definitely not
the danning trigger diagram with change
labels it's totally original i made it
so
on the horizontal
on the vertical
axis you have the viability of a project
of of a specific type of project using
minimal apis
and then on the horizontal you have the
type of project the way i imagine it
when it comes to project lifetime
because i think projects start in a
certain way and they end up in a certain
way if you have enough money
but you can also start at any point it
doesn't have to go through all the life
cycle
so first beginner projects it makes so
much sense to use minimal apis for
beginner projects
it's a no-brainer you can just start
with just four lines of code and you
have something there so we established
that also demos as you saw on the first
demo very easy to demo an api using
minimal apis and also proof of concepts
it's great to have a piece of technology
that you can just start building
something with and then convert that if
you want to something that can go to
production and be very very very
performant as well
now where i don't think they're going to
have an international career necessarily
is those chunky enterprise apps now
those are not limited to monoliths
beyond saving
modular monoliths can also be part of
this but i think that just because
the type of company the type of
developer who works on those projects
is a specific again type of developer
it doesn't make much sense to move from
one thing to another waste all of that
knowledge that exists in each company
and for that developer as well for
something that really isn't significant
because yes even if you did move to that
other structure you wouldn't really gain
much if you took that risk
so i definitely don't see that being
adopted there in my opinion for good
reason now if you make a new app and you
say we're going to give that a go then
maybe try it but
i just can't see it happening
but where i do see that something
amazing will happen is microservices now
microservices are small by nature is in
the name microservices so
minimal apis from microservices just
makes so much sense for me and it also
allows developers to work on
microservices to choose their own
destiny on the structure
i want to wrap this up
with the important the importance of
minimal apis for net because i think it
goes beyond the code
and beyond everything we talked about
until now
i want to talk about how people get into
a programming language in general
so first they have an idea they want to
build they don't know what programming
is that i'm just going to make a game
i'm going to remake tetris i don't know
how do i remake tetris on the
programming language what's the easiest
programming language to remake tetris
then university school quality just have
it as part of the classes and someone
might be like well that programming
thing sounds good i'm going to give it a
go and you just depend on whatever the
university or school decided for you to
learn
then curiosity is a beginner this is how
many people are starting i want to get
into programming how do i program how do
i make a calculator and it's all
downhill from there
or hopefully uphill
um curiosity is an experienced
programmer is another one this is how i
usually nowadays get into programming
languages because of how many features
are added in c shop
i really want to see where they're
getting inspired from spoiler alert it's
usually f-sharp
but other languages as well like kotlin
rust are a heavy influence to the
c-sharp team so i'm getting into those
languages to have a more spherical view
on how things are added
into
c-sharp
and then last but not least just because
you get hired into the company that is
using it this is how i start with
c-sharp i desperately need for a job i
was doing java beforehand for some
reason my future would be building
desktop applications in java
maybe not the smartest idea but someone
said here's a job
so i took it thanks phil you kinda
changed my life
but this is in general how people get
into programming languages there are
this as well
but
i'm going to focus on this you know a
parent is also another one and so on but
we're going to leave that outside
so
these three
are the ones directly applicable to c
sharp
now you could say no nick three and one
is also applicable because of unity the
game engine
and that is true but unity the game
engine if you've seen c sharp from unity
the game engine you
wouldn't really want to see that code
trust me it's it's weird it's a
different thing it's not the same thing
it kind of gets there but it's not the
developer
you would necessarily hire and it's not
the developer that would want to work
for apis anyway so let's leave it
outside
so this is what we have
but
this is the one
that is actually
really
on our own destiny our own hands we can
choose the destiny because universities
schools colleges they can change which
language they teach and companies they
can change which language they use so
curiosity's an experienced programmer is
actually the one
thing left again outside of unity on how
people can get into the language and
even unity if they decide to move away
from c sharp which i don't think will
ever happen but
if they do then we lose that as well
and that is bad
and the reason why this is bad
is a train
so let's talk about trains
this one would won't make so much sense
as the lego i'm just warning you
so people get on board the train
people stay on the train and people get
off the train
and the train will keep making the
journey as long as there are passengers
the moment there's no passengers the
train will just stop doing that because
it doesn't make any sense for the
journey to be made
so let's talk about the programming
language express
a people pick up a language
b
people use a language and they keep
using that language
and c people stop using that language
now a language is dying when a plus b
minus c is decreasing over time which
makes sense the more people that ditch
the language
or the if the people ditching the
language are more than the people
picking up the language and using it
then we kind of have a problem and
there's a bit of a catch-22 when it
comes to programming languages as well
because the more people use a language
the more people will use a language and
the less people that use a language the
more people will stop using a language
which is how it's an interesting dynamic
but it is how it is um
so c sharp is good at b and c but a is a
bit stale people picking up the language
especially in the context of asp.net
core and apis and that is not
c-sharp to blame because c-sharp is a
great language people love using c-sharp
and they just stick with it for years
upon years upon years but we need to
make it more accessible and make more
people come in and say hey we're cool
too you can also have an api very
quickly or you can also have a system
that you can deploy in the cloud very
very easily
c is inevitable as people retire like it
makes so much sense for net being 20
years old that you have some people
doing it for so long that they can just
retire and they don't work for it
anymore
minimal apis are ultimately a step
towards increasing a to get more people
picking up the language
so when i hear things like the dotnet
team should not be working on things
like this this is not for me
why are they wasting my time this is not
what i asked for this is not what i need
well
if you want to be able to
hire the next generation of csharp and
dotnet developers than it is for you
even if it's not for you
thank you very much and keep coding
do we have time for questions
uh
sure we have
nine minutes
so if i can see anyone so if you have
any questions
ask me now if not we can just call it
here and you can come over and ask me
okay let's do the second
[Applause]